[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as us chess champs calm
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome to the 2019
summer chess classic we are your hosts
my name is Caleb Denby and I'm joined by
the wonderful chess grandmaster author
commentator Jessie cry and it's an
exciting year this year we've got quite
a number of extremely talented and
strong up-and-coming players at this
summer chess classic it's actually the
strongest one I think we've ever had and
ou can actually take a look at who we
have playing today up in the group a we
have quite a number of players Sam
Shanklin 2018 u.s. champion is the top
seed for the a group he's followed
closely by Colin Jones the number one
English player and following him is the
number one Vietnamese player actually
look Longley am and then we have David
Howell so actually both the number one
and the number two English players are
here in st. Louis right now after him is
Jeffrey Zhang who is a very talented
junior player from the United States and
following him is Darius sweets and yeah
and coming up next is Group B we've got
Sam 7 the number one seed another US
player Egor Kovalenko following him is
Grigory Oberon Daniel Friedman sorry on
Ganguly and Havana's Debussy on and now
for group C got Dmitri Gordievsky our
turfs Naik Suns Christian Sharla Aramco
Cobian L Sean Marathi Abadi and rounding
up group C is Brandon Jacobson who will
actually be playing in the US Junior
Championships coming up pretty quickly
after this tournament right yeah so now
let's take a look at the format of this
tournament how these players are going
to be playing against each other so it's
actually three six player in double
round-robin so every player will play
each other at least twice maybe more if
there's a playoff but
the time control for the games is 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and they
get 30 minutes sudden-death for the
remainder of the game
with a 30 second increment from move 1
and the schedule of this tournaments
it's gonna be a it's gonna be pretty
tough there's only one rest day actually
so starting today is round 1 which
started at 1:00 p.m. and the only rest
day I believe comes on Sunday the 23rd
that's right it's a totally brutal
tournament 10 rounds is a lot it's gonna
be physically challenging and I'm
wishing the old guys in the field the
best of luck it's really hard to avoid
the senior moments when you know you've
got such a physically demanding schedule
absolutely yeah and thank you all for
joining us here on youtube if you want
to join us you're welcome to chat live
on the YouTube chat we will be taking a
look at that also use the Twitter
hashtag summer chess classic and watch
the games live on us chess champs calm
with all that in mind let's just jump
into the pairings for group a see what
the games are like we've got gaalan
Jones playing against Geoffrey Zhang
Darius sweets against laQuan Liam and
then our key matchup for the day is Sam
Shanklin versus GM David Howell so Sam
of course the number one seed in this
group with the white pieces against
David Howell he's definitely gonna have
to try and get out to an early lead I
think he wants to kind of keep this
tournament under control right and it's
a pretty violent game as we stand so
there you get us talk about it this
situation is really tricky here for
white and I'm gonna just let you guys
look at this for a second then we'll
back it up a little bit but Sam
definitely is taking some chances in
this position no especially this rook is
really hardcore you know the bishop is
looking at the part that's coming this
way this guy can move at any point and
the knight of course can be annoying so
on Sam's side what we can say is that if
he somehow can consolidate this position
without losing
something then he should be better
because the King on c8 is out of play
and the rook on a is out of play however
it is not an easy task here and we're
heading into time trouble too so expect
a think here from Sam while we're
talking about the moves and he's got to
come up with something significant now
so let me go back a little bit let's
just show the opening this is a very
standard Berlin and I was up there
watching it and actually is a funny
moment where even on move three David
how kind of thought about it here and so
you clearly he had more than one thing
you do but at the board decided to play
into this system and Shanklin played h3
here very quickly and clearly had let's
call it the opening advantage in that it
seemed like he knew what he was doing
and I wanted to say it here that I felt
like oh yeah Shanklin kind of got what
he wanted because the pawns are now
active and it's not going to be easy for
the bishop but for any of blacks pieces
to get out of course White has his own
problems and that's clear in these
pieces over here yes so long term I
guess black is just trying to not make
too many weaknesses and find a way to
get those pieces out like use those
bishops somehow well long term it's
especially this bishop
you're an opposed light square bishop
that black is gonna claim is gonna save
him and it's gonna be active enough to
save him so let's do a couple of moves
Knight ef3 I'm sure was also possible
but 94 b6 simple idea to give the King
some space but also to prepare c5 and
Bishop c6 the problem though is now c4
very good move this dynamic is going to
be
happening in the game as it's now stance
namely that when you play c5 you have to
worry about Knight c3 Knight d5 but
without playing c5 how are you gonna
play your Bishop on e8 black played age
five now for reasons I don't understand
Sam played King f2 this might all be the
same but just a human felt more human
the vlei King g2 and maybe he just
didn't want to be on the light squares
in general now black is gonna try to be
active and we're gonna have to say that
you successfulness when I looked at this
I did not think it was going to be
possible for black to be active but
let's look what he did Knight g6 Knight
bc3 Bishop e7 and you know I haven't
looked at this with a computer or
anything right I'm gonna guess that
Shanklin might regret this move here
where he commonly played the thematic b3
and maybe a move like King g3 or Bishop
e3 more natural moves developing moves
might have been called for oh so yeah it
does he just not have enough time so
play move like b3 right well let's look
at what happens so Bishop d7 and now
black says check to the misérable King
back and the threat is very simple it's
to take to play rook age three and then
to separate the King from the pawn okay
now yeah maybe let's talk about it
positionally here for a second if we
could just develop a little bit his
position would be amazing absolutely
amazing but this this tactic is a
problem and the first thing that Sam
could have done here is he could have
taken a draw with King g3 and Wright
would have gone back and forth
so now Sam besides know I'm gonna go for
it with Knight
sooo and the problem is is that night is
kind of hokey there it's not the most
natural square it's not the most natural
square and it's going to be the green
light for black to get active which is
what how old does instantly wear a snips
and plays f5 and now it's a real
uncomfortable situation for Shanklin
because if he takes he liberates the
bishop and if he doesn't take he gives
up all chances of ever being better
because this pawn will be on a dark
square and these light squares will be
amazing Wow right you could even play
Knight f-86 would be better for black so
he had to go for it mm-hmm Bishop b2 and
now c5 was a simple and cruel move
people and cruel say enough of the
Knights pins you're not so worried about
the d5 square right now long term you
still are gonna have to worry about it
but here we're gonna get to our
situation right now
rook d2 and now rook f8 let me get rid
of all those arrows it looks like a
football day so one key variation I
think is what happens if I do the
natural move Knight d5 and I think the
problem there might be more than one
problem but the thing I saw was snip
snip and c6 and I didn't understand how
white held DF 4 yeah I guess that you
really can't so if you can't do your the
move you want to do there's gonna be
some drama for example if you ever move
the knight this way if black has nothing
else he always has this beautiful check
and let's just say the dream of the
Berlin is to have that on a post light
square bishop and have it later in the
game come out and be active and that's
definitely the fear now that shank Lindh
is living with okay it seems like the
the two pawns on the Kings side just
can't control all the squares right
you'd love to I don't know to play f5
and have that pawn you know defended but
then you give up the e5 square in the g5
Square and you'd love to play g5 to get
rid of that Bishop but then you give up
the f5 Square
and so it's and well g5 I guess it's
also losing the pawn here but right and
so Franklin maybe it looks like he had
to do it so he did play a f5 and I think
it was actually a variety of moves that
black could have done here yeah I was
expecting something like Knight e5 95
and notice Bishop g5 is also a move
Wow yeah right so there was all kinds of
worry shady to me hit for white but 9h
for I have to say it feels to me now
we're about to see what how's intention
is here but it feels to me that how old
really does need something special now
because both Knight d5 and 94 are coming
fast and then your knight on so h4 is
stranded I had a very silly idea sure
tell me use what if I play Bishop e5
check let's look at it that's very nice
it should be five now it looks like I
kind of sort of have to take the thing
so yeah if you take and I play Bishop f4
very nice very nice or are you
checkmated maybe you know you called it
you old it's on the board
yeah it's on the board let me get that
and I think what we're seeing is okay
let's just put your move Bishop Bishop
f4 is also on the board okay so you're
you're the champ today okay I don't know
I don't see anything special here for
Shanklin I don't know how you can stop
this let's just say it takes it still
mate yeah so you can obviously like lose
the exchange but that's just totally
lost well no I mean how did how do you
even lose the exchanging h3 thing h3
yeah okay you got me there oh yeah but I
think that's just totally done so Wow
all right well a lot for Sam to think
about do you want to take a look at
what's going on in Group E oh he did
play King h3 that poor guy Wow alright
so you kind of just admitting it so
so let's just say this is that this is a
terrible thing when you're the top seed
and you lose control of the game and
because you went for it yeah right and
let me just revisit digress moment where
it was King f3 Bishop e7 and you could
have just gone back to King g3 but
instead Sam
allowed his pieces to become this
coordinate with Knight of 2 and then we
got this hellacious position where I
didn't know exactly what's going on but
I definitely was like oh oh is the
provinces in there oh we got a problem
and let's read and so in this position I
didn't know what he was supposed to do
but f5 met this brilliant thing and I'm
just gonna use that you saw it check and
you got to take Bishop f4 and it's game
over
that's tough so I yeah I don't see a way
white really can even hold on here I
mean you can play on down the exchange
and try to use that F pawn I guess right
we'll come back to see if Sam
miraculously escapes but he's gonna need
a little luck to do that so yeah on to
the group B now let's see what those
pairings are like oh we got Soriana
ganguly playing against igor Kovalenko
Gregorio Pirin against the Busey on and
then our key matchup for Group B is
actually Sam 7 another youngster from
the u.s. playing against Daniel Friedman
so let's take a look at that game and
what's going on here yeah let's take it
from the top and one thing about this
Petrov opening is in the last 10 years
it's evolved from this kind of
theoretical struggle to this very
double-edged struggle which is less to
my mind less theoretical because in this
position black has so many different
setups right that he can go for white
set up is easy he's gonna move the
bishop on c1 put the Queen somewhere it
casts a long and try to mate black
that's right that's what's gonna go on
but black has so many different ways
that I feel like I'm sure for the very
top players its theoretical in the sense
that they've scoped out a lot of the
different plans but while I was watching
this game it felt to me like both
players were thinking pretty early and
so it was just it's nice because it's a
chess game here all right h4 and already
with h4 Sam is dreaming about planting
something on g5 which he's gonna say is
not gonna go away because if you ever
take me I'm gonna open the rook and if
the rook has developed then I don't need
to develop the bishop it's developed
where it isn't right
okay rook e8 black I'm sure had various
moves here Knight g5 h6 and here we go
f3 f3
so yeah just right away just you can't
it you can't touch my knight BH files
too important but I don't think black
was ever actually planning to take the
knife right maybe something like 95 here
and trying to fight back on the dark
squares 95 won't work because of the
brutal this Oh a base 7 and Knight f7
but yeah you you're probably you're
gonna have to play h6 sometime anyway
and what you do is you kind of hold the
threat of hg over white's head don't
worry about it here's a nice move c5
black wants counter play and he wants to
deny Bishop d4 in any later yeah like
right now right g4 according to plan
Queen a5 and Sam thought forever I was
up there watching this and he thought
forever on this move it was unclear to
me maybe we'll get a chance and what he
was thinking about because that seemed
natural and then B 5 and this is what
I'm talking about there's another game
we'll probably talk about today as well
with the karo and the karo with the
advanced variation has also turned
incredibly violent like this with your
opposite sides castling and it is a pure
mess so beautiful struggle this this was
a question I had yeah so it seems like
black decided I want this Bishop on a
fate I want this knight on f6
and then I'm just gonna start attacking
so how do you like come across a setup
like that when your opponent's kind of
just starting to push or push their
pawns on your king side how do you say
this is the defensive setup I want
honestly I think he was thinking about
it you see it from the times both
players they just were like you know I
think yeah sure defense the dark squares
yeah
and he's he this guy is a real problem
the bishop on see it doesn't know where
to go so we're gonna wait with this one
and this one to see how it shakes out on
the Queen side right so for example
after 94 which is what happened this
will then be black skew to put the
bishop there and now her a-ha we get an
endgame wonderful the bishop on e4 is of
course hitting the rook and let's
consider this last move for a second
mortals would have probably played rook
a b8 but the problem for black is that
on CB rook b5 there's bishop c6 disaster
now you could have also played d5 here
that would have been a fully human
approach so rook AC 8 has some
interesting intentions of just saying I
think I'm gonna be down upon and
afterward Bishop d3 this is what
happened
there should be three c4 black is making
a nice claim that the pawn on b5 is
insignificant the bishop on f8 is going
to come and touch all those loose start
squares and the bishop on d3 is going to
really ruin the coordination in the
whites position and here for example and
want to play if you play Bishop e2 I
assume you know there's some like Bishop
g4 will probably happen okay and if you
play Bishop f1 you're just pretty upset
about life in general yeah it's black
just playing something like d4 and then
c3 just immediately maybe he could just
compat himself on the back first of all
you got the bishop to f1 and then
you know white is considering Bishop f5
here but the problem of course is not
just the double points but then you know
the rook will come down right also yeah
and your move of d4 c3 is always you
know yeah yeah so what do you what do
you think here do you like this for
black then or is I that extra pawn might
might be somewhat relevant right you can
play a four and try to hold on to it no
of course it's relevant but um it's not
going to be relevant for awhile why it's
the one who decides what kind of game we
get yeah I would say just intuitively
that Bishop b2 of Bishop f1 are gonna be
fine for black so let's consider Bishop
f5 okay
now black probably has more than one
move but let's just say takes and now
again we have more than one move yeah I
I would be a little hesitant maybe to
just play something like rookie to when
their moves like f6 maybe crew well also
we have might have to worry a little bit
about Bishop c3 that as well but yeah
so I mean I assume Bishop f5 is on the
board so that did happen all right that
was kind of a process of elimination
kind of thing because the other ones
were so you almost have to have to have
to do something now maybe we can try to
divine his intentions here because this
was the moment where black decided with
rook a c8 you know to do his plan
whereas he could have unless I'm missing
something he could have picked up the
pawn like that yeah yeah you were saying
- like here and snip and then d5 I would
definitely agree that this is no this
doesn't necessarily mean that this that
his move was worse it's just like he has
some he has some deeper intention with
here where he's saying I don't need the
pawn and I guess I'm gonna be doing
something with the C pawn yeah there's
like just some uncomfortable pressure
where the dark square Bishop ever lifts
itself up c3 can kind of come and I have
to say I don't get it yeah yeah let's
say but well okay let's try to imagine
it for black so
basically as white what I'm thinking is
if whenever you do d4 whether you take
on f5 first or not there's something
like this should be 1 2 F - yeah a
little pressure there's as well but I
mean there's already gonna be pressure
on the deep on if it takes occurs on f5
right you have to like take 6 on i-5 and
then the deep on it's kind of already
loose well yeah so what do we do
I mean can you let the bishops it may be
I don't know I this is a thread until
yeah right I feel like that's the clear
positional threat I feel like I want to
play rook b8 and then take my pawn -
yeah we don't want to do that yeah he
doesn't want to do that if he does he'll
be upset with himself Daniel's got
different intentions somehow well let's
look at this again Bishop takes pawn
takes get rid of this arrow and then the
question is what can black do
I just think they're there's so many
good moves for white white wants to play
f6 so Islands play we should see three
white wants to play with g1 and let's
say I just don't care
this is kind of an ugly move but they'll
say yeah I'll start with f6 like alright
so we'll take this thing I want to check
you with my a truck okay
there's nothing immediate I guess yeah
my f-pawn is gonna be weak right Alan
bishops III planning I guess Rick at
5:00 I mean honestly I just want to say
this does not look aesthetically
appealing to me to play rookie five yeah
but I'm just trying to figure out what
his intention was there could be also an
intention hey the other hint to me that
rookie five is his intention is that now
Bishop f4 doesn't skewer my business
ah okay so you had seeing the tactics
the patterns beforehand and giving
himself that extra option maybe he's
deadly thinking about well I guess let's
give him some time to consider that and
check out maybe Group C sure what the
pairings look like for we've got Brandon
Jacobson versus Christian shrila our
tourism Mike's aunts versus Alshon rowdy
body and Gordievsky playing aram huh
Cobian yeah and you know though our King
a trip for the day was actually I guess
Gordievsky against Hagopian that wasn't
like he I met well that's so you wanted
to look at Brandon Jacobson in fact
maybe we'll jump over there I want to
tell our crew that if we can get Brandon
in here for an interview I would love to
talk to him about this game yeah it's
play we'll get him down here I've been
actually so of course their game has
ended is what we're talking about here
so let's take a look and see how that
game actually won baby it was really
pretty interesting I have to say I there
were points to the game where I was
mystified and maybe Christian trilha the
count was also mystified so I'm sure
this is often very familiar to both
players here d5
ok so white says you can take my pawn
and then white says I'm gonna play h4
Wow ok and I felt this was probably this
is this is still the kids theory because
he was playing it pretty head the kid
you anybody and now anyone playing us
jr. as a kid so this is definitely still
theory
but so uh what's the idea with h4
usually you see that with the rook you
know on h1 kind of supporting it but
just claiming some dark squares or is he
planning age five to break down that
Kings side definitely planning h5 and as
we see in the game he has this naughty
intention of playing rook b3 and over
and I have to say like one thing that's
you know beautiful about this game is
black has several different defensive
setups I feel like he could now go for
right the count chooses a very solid
what looked to me very solid right 97
rook b3 Bishop g7 and very very brutal
now let me just say this right to the
point what would what would be
interesting to talk to Brandon about is
what I couldn't figure out his eyes I
said to myself
yes it's very clever that the rook gets
to go to h3 but how do you get the Queen
over to like H for something it was vit
that part of it was very unclear to me
see part of blacks problems though are
just positional one it's hard for him to
get counter played by advancing these
pawns he's obviously up a pawn and he
would like to get you know play with
those pawns and it's also hard for this
Bishop to get in at least he owes us a
move or so for that Bishop to do
something well before we get too far
into this attack I think Brandon is
actually ready to come in great so I'm
gonna actually step out of the studio
and we'll get Brandon in here to give
you his thoughts on the game all right
so I'm gonna while he's coming in I'll
just peek at this a couple other games
here in this in Cobian against
Gordievsky it's been interesting for a
while and I felt like white probably had
a slight edge for some time here but
it's obviously a mess
anything could happened there el Shawn
played very provocatively as he does but
I think he has a nice position again
our tortoise snake sons who's the name
I'm probably butchering but that's
pronouncing with a nice attack on the d4
pawn and a game I want to look at while
we're waiting is Geoffrey Zhang's game
we haven't talked about it much I did
refer earlier to the karo being a
violent opening now because of this ePHI
variation and I hope we can get the
players in here to to talk about this
game because it was very I felt it was
very provocative the way Geoffrey played
in this game where his king is gonna
constantly be on the move and maybe here
was a moment right around here we're
going might have been able to play more
actively all right we have Brandon
coming in the studio a beautiful win so
we're gonna get a chance to ask him some
questions about what was going on so
glad you're here congratulations yeah
now if you want you can tell me to move
or you could just you know take over the
controls yourself however you'd like to
do it okay sure
and let's start let's say with b6 yeah
so in the database he's played this
quite a number of times i okay so it was
pretty predictable yeah and I thought
this spawn sack plan would be pretty
dangerous okay good good preparation and
he didn't really he didn't really know
about this I'm gonna give it a feeling
yeah yeah no Caleb said well usually
when you play it for there's a rook
behind it eventually you're gonna go age
595 try to bring your record Queens of
the age file and that's Bishop on b7 is
misplaced and it's already really
dangerous for a black to try to defend
here
right and I guess there's my sense one
things that's impressive to me about
this game is I'm sure you kind of had
some plans here but there's a lot of
different things black and try yeah
right there so you couldn't like map it
out totally right I mean I was trying to
but I'm not really I'm sure there are
plenty of options for black here that
having his plan looked at least the
first two moves looked fine right yeah I
think after roughly three though Bishop
f6 should be a better move so the idea
is that if I try to play take in a
Knight g5 like I did in the game black
house King g7 and there's rugby Jade
defense I see let's let's maybe point
that out so Bishop f6 and Knight g4
Knight g5 one of those oh yeah one of
those let's say night chief well 95
keeps the tension then he can't do the
King bee 7 I'm that right away maybe she
takes the h5 unless you're sure yeah
that wouldn't take that would take some
[Laughter]
maybe that would also take you don't
know you know it's dangerous
yeah you have it very nice that actually
shows how dangerous this initiative is
yeah for you when out one thing I want
to ask you is so I saw this position
okay rook age 3 and I was like that was
very creative what he just did but I
said to myself how is the Queen get over
there it seemed it seemed hard for the
Queen to get I mean the idea as long as
I'm stopping he's 6 it's kind of hard
for plots and move around so I don't
have to do something immediate I can try
to build up a 5 maybe with that 4 at
some point mm-hmm or later with rook age
for Queen b3 Queen Age 3 in some cases
even g3 came g2 bringing the rotation
the idea is if I'm just stopping back
from breaking in the center then I
time to look at my position maybe night
if six wasn't the best try yeah I
thought I was considering going
you could play Bishop f6 here rook h3
King G seven anyway it looks risky but I
can really find a follow up there maybe
just c4 for a black here yeah yeah
something like that
well and maybe I don't understand his
intention like what is the idea of night
s6 I mean probably he just played that
automatically just trying to defend and
the idea your ship c8 at some point so
to keep my pieces off the h-file good I
think we can see it in his next three
moves right his intention is that when
his bishop comes to see it he will at
least try to mess with your coordination
a little bit another thing is there a
lot of positions there is this idea of
Knight takes e4 and it takes d5 uh-huh
so if I have to trade Queens then we'll
have three pawn for the piece and it's
still unclear okay have to be prepared
for that so here how confident were you
here after Queen c2 I think my positions
already pretty good here because his
idea is if I play something else
we'll go Queen e5 either after a bishop
seater here uh-huh
but if Queen e5 here the idea of a queen
c2 is to sort of defend the Queen side
because then f4 Queen d4 Bishop e3
doesn't really have a follow up there
right you can also draw in Bishop c8
first but then I'll have rook age for
cleaning five Bishop f4 huh he sort of
forced back here for Queen c2
yeah it's yeah it's a fun position
because I'm like well it's not exactly
clear how you're gonna made him or maybe
it was clear to you I mean yeah I don't
I didn't see any immediate I didn't even
know what my next move would be but
right I mean it's sort of hard for Platt
to like like Estonians 3 moves ok a 6 B
5 c4 and even then what even then right
what are you gonna do huh okay well he
tried to eat fine and now you really did
the full dance of the Queen to b3 so
you're saying in this position you
weren't certain but then after e5 yes
you saw the g3 square exactly right so
then I can try to break up one with that
for like I didn't thinking I think
that's already really unpleasant for
black yeah it's interesting where the
extra pawn is totally meaningless yep
right totally meaningless so f4
beautiful simple play high c4 I think
you're just a blender you probably have
to fire rook to e8 and then there are a
few different after Queen g3 and there
are a few things I can do probably a
queen h2 interesting
okay yeah let's talk about it so queen
h2 and let's say I gave you another move
what's what's your idea so probably my
next pivot it should be to simply me -
yeah he always have to watch out for
ideas if the night's not enough Sixers
for DJs oh and this would be a good
moment to say this night would be better
on f8 yeah exactly right because on
Knight d7 there's this brutal istic
thing here yep okay yeah that's that's
nice it's and the simple thing to say
here is it's just really hard to say
what black should do next yeah I know
I'll tell you what though I'll be the
guinea pig and I'll say c4 I don't think
you should have been doing that a long
time ago yeah maybe I should start with
Bishop b2 last minute man yeah the c-4
is no sir
so instead of d2 Bishop b2 now yeah yeah
that makes sense okay now this entire
time I was just like let's if you know
give you the exchange if you want it
well I've still a bishop a3 now my
Queen's Own g3 oh that's a bummer well
right so I would have to yeah it's hard
to say what I should do let's say I
let's say this doesn't look right but
let's just do this
probably rotation ticks and then
I mean again what's your next move right
so I'm just trying to survive yeah you
know maybe Route 87 yeah okay but now a
beautiful position beautiful win tell us
about your life right now what's going
on
you're gonna play us junior next month
yeah and how old are you I'm 15 15 so
you're still going to high school
I'm in college actually you're in
college oh yeah where are you going to
college
Columbia that's very exciting and how
much time do you have for chess oh this
summer I'm trying to play as much as I
can before this semester starts that's
amazing
okay beautiful are you training with
anybody or how is it working yeah
lessons sometimes okay well I'm gonna be
back doing the commentary for the US
Junior so hopefully I'll get another
magnificent win like this and I will get
to talk to it again all right thanks for
coming in thank you
so beautiful victory by Brandon and I
hope to see him again soon that was I
thought a beautiful game you know 26
moves it's already over so really nice
let's take a look at Sam's game to see
if there's any chance of survival so we
got up here and poor Sam let's check in
on him
as expected he is down the exchange and
Caleb what's happening in this position
well it's good to be back after that
awesome interview with Brandon Jacobson
that was quite the game he had yeah
what's going on here so Black has more
rooks
and more passed pawns that looks like
but it's I don't know mm I miss counting
but white seems to have two nights for
the rook all of a sudden let's go back
and see how this thing that if something
is happy
so King we decided when we left that
black had just played this beautiful
Bishop f4 and it seemed on the surface
of things that it was all over now we
should note that there is some counter
play and that at least this pawn is a
subject of attack so Knight ce4 oh okay
rook d1 interesting so so there's some
g5 at some point trapping the bishop is
right in order for the black King to
move he has to first play something like
Bishop c6
and when he does then the f5 pawn no
longer falls with check so hilariously I
don't know how hilarious - everybody
visited me his little hilarious is that
both Caleb and I saw this thing and we
were like oh no it's the south it's too
pretty to be bad but right have you fans
saw for everything anyone well I'm sure
he missed it but he's found at least a
resource here where I don't know what's
going on now King d7 and now rook d2
and of course of the minor pieces to
have for a rook to Knights is really not
not the imbalance you would you would
prefer you know given your choice of any
two minor pieces but there's still like
no joke maybe black is planning rook f8
here to try to let's put rook a date on
the board to see because I don't
obviously that's the move you wanna play
but I think the answer is quite simple
is that no I don't think that's a good
move actually because what Shanklin can
say is no I have the dark square bishop
you have the light squares and what that
means is I own the dark square so you
better not even mess with me hmm
Wow and so one really interesting
feature about end games like this is
that the opposite color bishops change
the nature of the struggle and in
particular now the knight on f6 can't be
moved as far as I can tell so in that
one you're just showing that yeah there
is just Bishop d7 check let's look King
f5 Bishop d7 King g6 well you were
talking about how you owned the own the
dark squares I was trying to own the
light squares but I guess Bishop ease I
don't know it's not doing what I want it
to do I guess you want you wanted to do
what you're thinking I know what your
king out of so write this this
remarkable situation where it's hard to
imagine that black is in any trouble
however the knight on f6 is very strong
yeah really really remarkable position
there have been a couple end games
recently where the defend the the guy
who got slaughtered like Shanklin did
survive because the opposite color
bishops and what it means is simply that
no matter what the imbalance the going
forward whether you're down the exchange
or have the two nights like this for the
rook your bishop
is the master of at least half the board
right and so black you notice White's
put all his pieces on dark squares
except the King though that might come
soon to a dark square he can't touch us
on any of those squares and the bummer
for black to is he has to be careful if
I get say this Knight to a square like a
five you know things could get kind of
kind of scary right maybe black should
just tried to activate the rest a little
bit more maybe something like herb g7
Jack well that's what he did he played
rook g7 check and I think if I click on
the board I can get it
I don't know really what the black plan
here is you know because what White's
got a simple plan he wants to bring the
he's gonna move the king somewhere and
then look to put the night now here's a
potential actually issue that he has did
Sam has to at least worry about right if
I do something like King f5 then there's
rook g2 so yeah getting getting the rut
game and more more importantly than just
getting the brook and what black really
wants these positions is he wants to
trade the rook the white rook for one of
his ropes and it's a very simple idea
where black is gonna say my two rooks do
the same kind of thing
and your rooks and knights do different
things so I want to take away right that
ability and I'll get rid of my own
redundancy so I know what I would always
want as the black player here and that's
I have a passed pawn and if I can't
figure out what to do I just I want to
try to push it but it's got to get past
age five first of all that guy's that
guy's toast in fact you could argue that
that pawn is a hindrance more than
anything else because at least now if I
want to I can put my cape on the h-file
otherwise it would be art now the the
fact of the matter is black is going to
get to g2 and that is a big bonus for
him because I think what its gonna mean
is that the rook will get traded off
right well maybe I'm wrong about that
look so let's check so let's just say
the natural king f5 now you can check me
if you want you might as well sure I
think I gotta go there let's just
pretend they do and then here is there
any way that I can get out without
trading my rooks
and maybe I just point something out if
94 we can imagine a variation like this
this is like the worst case for weight
this would be blacks dream because here
he has earnest chances to win where this
is a great position for the roof there's
no there's no squares for white to sink
this teeth into and the rook will
eventually find its way into the seventh
rank so that's that's the drama you know
looks like King f4 was played so let's
click on that and I'm expecting rip d2
but it might not eat you you might not
even be in a rush to do it maybe you can
come up with something else
yeah so the big thing keeping black back
here in my opinion is that the rook on
a8 it doesn't have any easy way into the
game so I was thinking maybe if black
can find the time you just come in to f8
and then to f7 and you just followed the
same path as the other rook but it's
it's really tough to find any other way
to get that rook in the game right I
think I think the guys who play brooms
you do without thinking about it boom
yeah okay well that was Shanklin trying
to find some way not to trade off all
that business I don't I don't actually
you know it's a real bummer for him this
is move 37 I guess so they've got a few
more moves to make before time control
they everything a bit low and I just say
that in this very interesting position
maybe a rook d2 was inaccurate hmm would
you like to see it I just don't want
that rook g2 to land on me and then have
to here's a thought though here's a
thought maybe Shanklin could think about
it this way and say to himself you know
what it's cool that you put your rook on
g2 but I will try to say that I never
have to move the knight
yeah and that's is it true I don't know
it might maybe that's what I think
awaits thinking about like maybe King f5
now totally clear what I'm doing
that I don't have to move the night yeah
the thing is black never has to move the
rook either no no of course so it seems
as though my rook is keeping both your
rook and your knight kind of a moving
for a while at least and you know what
you were talking about that a8 rook I'm
sure something black is thinking about
is a5 ah and if a four then this one
will be weak rip g2 was played and I
think yeah I think this is a challenge
for white to figure out a plan here yeah
very interesting position you know one
thing that I like about the Berlin a lot
is although I don't play it myself is I
can imagine studying it and getting some
ideas and you just have interesting
chances in the endgame and if you want
to really kind of specialize in end
games this would be a great opening it's
you know it's also just to learn end
games from because you get these
beautiful imbalances like this Bishop on
c6 who's such a beautiful piece and you
get you get it a lot so you would get
common themes where you get to play
again and again unfortunately it's so
popular that like Sheikh Lin is busting
out what was at h3 early and he clearly
knew you know he had a kind of mapped
out at least the first part he was ready
for it
yeah let's look at Jeffrey's game we'll
come back that's when we haven't seen
yet today but I think it was it was a
pretty intense oh I guess you went over
it briefly but very briefly and the
thing I want to say about is I was very
provocative the way Jeffrey played
honestly just to even allow this
position these days I feel as a pocket
'iv because what white is getting
especially after you have to play h5 is
yes you are gonna get a structure that's
like the French and your bishop will be
outside the pawn chain but you're gonna
owe white a tempo
and if you have to play h5 which
nowadays they're kind of doing them in
obligatory way this Square and then
potentially later this square are gonna
be weakened as a French player myself I
get real queasy or I see that fair
enough
so let's take a look at what happens
here so very fair play the idea of Queen
a5 is eventually I'm gonna play Queen a6
and maybe three is simple and beautiful
working against this c5 break and this
is the position that if I get going in
here later
maybe I just go hang out later and get a
chance to talk to but I felt like this
was the moment where he needed to find a
clear plan right because the next three
or so moves I felt like he didn't it
didn't feel like he knew what he was
doing and even though but we should say
even if white does absolutely nothing
here for the next couple moves blacks
king will always be in danger
right it's just like it doesn't know
where it's gonna go it's going to be in
danger and so rights first to was kind
of just like I'm gonna build the
position and see what's gonna happen but
I yeah I still didn't like him I wanted
to put a piece on rather than g5 and I
want it be nice organize some kind of
some kind of something with an item d3
he eventually plays a4 a5 and that would
certainly I feel me not a bad start to
this position to just play a4 a5 and
there tell the black Queen that not only
gonna crimp your style a little bit in
the knight coming to b6 but I might play
a six if you ever move this is something
like I noticed about this variation is
not only is your King kind of stuck in
the center but you've kind of sidelined
your Queen as well which is one of the
most useful defensive pieces it's just
it's always six and it's gonna take a
few moves to get it back anywhere where
it can help and this is the critical
question but you know the interesting
debate here you know thing for black is
he it's decide when to play
see five and the second he does it it's
like the nature of the game completely
shifts from a closed game to a violent
game and what Gawain does is he kind of
continues to not do anything he says
he's just sitting here and the next
couple moves not so impressive but he's
just sitting on him you get the feeling
that he didn't quite know what to do
now Bishop c5 I thought was an
interesting move because you would
expect Knight see fine but the notion I
guess is that if you take my bishop
this night will land on this square so I
know the big thing usually in this
structure is if the bishop does get
traded off then stuff like the d6 square
is always gonna be a sure but I guess
there's really no clear way to to make
use of that here or even the d4 square I
guess is kind of being given up by
trading off this bishop but I don't know
I would much rather have that knight on
e4 I think then I care about either of
those things right so King G - and I
didn't I wasn't thrilled about this one
night f8
by the way a six was a nice move too
because it just said I'm gonna wait and
I just didn't want I don't ever want you
to play a six right and I'm gonna try to
keep your pawns when I say you are I
mean white spawns on dark squares so
that this Bishop remains bad and I say
that's one of the key problems going
forward for white is especially if you
trade off this knight then you're just
left poking around in the dark squares
and blacks Knight can you know start
hopping in the light squares that's the
danger now for white in this position
there should be three no trade ninety
seven beautiful so he's gonna work he's
gonna dance the light squares yeah he's
he's already kind of achieved it where
he's and what can this Bishop attack if
there's no pieces he he could take and
get that night I think the night versus
Bishop is favorable it's probably gonna
happen anyway but I like you know I'll
say this with Geoffrey is that we
covered his games in the Fall Classic to
here and I was left to say I was a
spectator watching them and he's played
a lot of provocative chest especially
it's black come attack me chest and what
was funny about this game is normally he
plays the Sicilian but he clearly
intended to play this situation he aimed
for this kind of weird game and it's
like now the problem for white is if you
don't hurt if you don't take the
opportunity to hurt black something like
this is gonna happen where white is the
one who has I think the danger
especially now in the light squares
queen c8 g6 just taking our time and now
he finally castles isn't it nice you're
on move 28 hit guess it's time now we're
playing a game here where white is
claiming that if I ever take on d4 that
black isn't gonna have
enough I guess that's the claim yeah oh
you definitely prefer black here right
oh yes yeah you can yeah yeah yeah go
any other way with it but he got rid of
his bishop and that was a good thing so
I guess that was the point of be for it
was to allow this Bishop c5 move even
though you're kind of making c3 weakness
right so black is definitely still
better and the you know let's just say
something kind of obvious you've got the
French structure in the pawn on e5 your
job really is to crack black on the
Kings side whether his King is there or
not you still want to crack him on the
King side and it's hard to see how
that's achievable here but I guarantee
that Gawain is at least thinking about
organizing some kind of G for the bummer
for him though is that the rook on a3
seems passive and out of play and the
without that you also and of course you
have to worry about the breakthrough on
c3 so it still seems like even though
black gifted white the exchange of the
bishop it came at the cost of this
structural problem and here we have him
oh this is beautiful I love when we get
to watch the players
it's like queen up for I guess let's
take a look it looks like Queen III so
yeah for you know for played that's an
interesting move see I was gonna ask
this obviously black wants all of his
major pieces on the C file but I wasn't
sure which square he wanted to go with
with his Knight looks like he chose c6
let's let's let's look at this because
we were talking and they played a couple
moves would be 396 23 no it's just very
simple indirect play you know just do he
doing all this stuff
Queen f4 it honestly feels like we're
just waiting now yeah it's it's
interesting I guess wait didn't want to
take on c6 and that would be a move that
would kind of jump out to me is cuz this
knight on c6 is kind of attacking my e
pawn and
that makes me uncomfortable and I didn't
like it but well he's he's trying to say
that he has better defensive chances if
you we get you to take on d4 I see let's
look at your suggestion and I think the
idea is that there's long term there's
no hope we're very bleak right whereas
here if at least if you take my rook on
b3 we'll get out I see Black has a
number of good moves here let's let's
stay here for a second there's coming
into deep time trouble Knight d4 is well
they call it yeah 94 happened and I'm
wondering if he's gonna play f5 now
that's maybe too weird looks a little
strange you would rather have the
backwards Jeep on than the backwards
f-pawn I guess
well I'm just saying when you take there
was no rush to take on D for this rook
is now liberated so we are gonna have to
worry a little bit more about rook the
rook f3s of the world the reason I
actually don't like f5 is I think that's
probably bad I'm gonna say that's
probably bad but Queen g5 is a little
bit annoying yeah and then just the f6
squared + 6 squared I still think this
is very pleasant for black yeah I think
I'd prefer it the move that came to my
mind which is Queen e7 okay hitting
before and then clearing the way maybe
just invade what their works so that's a
do be fine I guess this is the first
wave I should have checked so let's just
think about it so obviously if you move
the Queen you release the tension on a5
so then my next idea I still want to
pressure this before pawn but maybe I
should do it with Queen d7 and then
coming into b5 that's a thought another
thing you could dream about is b5 saying
that if you take I will get incredible
pressure here and here D for pressure
III was just always gonna be wary of
touching any pawns on the Queen side cuz
I feel like if white can trade off one
set of those pawns
I thought his chances to hold would kind
of increase but Geoffrey did it the old
school way the old school way open the
file
invade on the file and let's just say
something very basic about the French
structure is that Oh often if pieces get
traded off it's white whose space
advantage not only disappears because
it's meaningless if there's no pieces
but he will be the one who has
weaknesses so if we look at in
particular at that d4 pawn and the b4
pawn but especially the d4 pawn it's
simply a weakness that black doesn't
have so rooks III might not be the best
move but it certainly is very unpleasant
because there's no risk for black and
the Queen is going to come down
to some kind of see 3 or C 2 squared
depending on what weight does let's say
the natural move for white would be
something like rookie 3 but then there's
so many things you've got to worry about
in addition to takes you've got to worry
about rook c1 for example so yeah I mean
just thinking if 2 more pieces get
traded off and then like a rook or a
queen lands on on sea floor you really
can't defend both B 4 and E 4 at the
same time that's know it's grim it's
really grim I play the CARICOM and this
is this is what I want out of life but
all right I'll defend for this guy for a
second here so let's say B for B 1 so
I'll take on b3
all right so snip-snip then let's see I
want to play Queen c2 I got a track
counter playing okay see I'll just play
your ex e7 and I got a try counter play
okay
even more counter well that's my side of
the board it's like I got a do something
okay it feels ten moves too late maybe I
guess moves are happening on the board
but this is what white wants to do says
you know he invention plays rook III and
it's a similar idea and this gives
Geoffrey - nice choices there's rook b3
and rook c1 the rooks c1 actually it
kind of jumps out is the problem with
rook c1 is that you got to figure
something out about that move right you
see why I wanted to play a fiver yeah so
probably let's I'm gonna say just in the
way he's been playing rugby 3 would be
the most consonant with that yeah it's
just simple you take the rook off the
board you get closer to closer to being
able to pick off one of those this will
be similar to our last variation if we
do something like this
so I was considering uh you see I got to
do this right because you're gonna
you're gonna start taking on my positive
yeah it's happening very soon it might
be happening now I wanted to take on g4
maybe and come in with Queenie for huh
yeah I have drawn chances by taking at
playing rookie three so yeah you take
that pawn and then uh my idea was I can
play at some point my king up to h5 and
then the pressure on hopefully the deep
on in the H pawn I might also go for it
with Queen g5 right but yeah something
like that white has to desperately try
to get play rook c1 was played haha see
what play and wait so we guess that much
and okay the problem I had here was I
didn't know how you effectively buckle
f7 down him he goes for the passive rook
FA well yeah passive with that piece but
allowing something like Queen C for now
is very I think this is dangerous okay
so let's think about Queen c4 does have
a mate threat let's just put that out
there so you have to play out of the
rook F to d3
I guess he's got three moves left
very very touchy he would like to play
g4 but it looks like it's okay so g4 is
an option Queen d2 is the back it up
option but actually that just looks bad
actually you know let me just say this
my prejudice is that with the rook on f8
it's unclear to me how that works it's
not clear to me how you are gonna break
white with just two pieces well yeah I
want to play Queen's soup or that's
let's say that's a g4 I'll play Queen c4
and then some piece to d3
so even that one you're saying so
correct me if I'm wrong but that's black
I think I should always be taking on on
g4 rather than let you take on anybody
that's just sue me I think and now at
least I don't hit your routine anymore
and I what if I just take your pawn
queen six before okay so here's the
threat
yeah
why it's thinking about it right and how
this is doubly worse them not only
Queenie one but Queen B one as well
right you can't really stop one scares
me a little less but yeah
g4 was played Wow holy moly it's
happening I mean he has to his notion
you know at the very beginning when
you're playing against the French
structure you're gonna have to try to
crack black or else it's just eventually
all gonna fall apart
so it takes G on the board and I think
that will transpose if he takes Queen
takes now arguably he doesn't - it seems
like he has to Ruth g3 or maybe even
rook d3 that could be clever yeah I
think I'd rather I'd rather wait to
commit that rook before I but it's just
so it's just like you need to have an
answer to this so yeah maybe the other
rook to to d3 but then I was thinking so
no a trick F 2 D 3 is you mean right
here yeah but then I was thinking there
might be a some clever way to play like
rook b1 okay but if I'm gonna do that
why don't I just do it now and then I'm
also threatening aged five but notice I
can always know now this f5 is always
coming
yeah there's oh wow especially with
without the cheap on then right okay so
this would be this would be quite
interest okay so the natural queen takes
is played and so one more move to time
control to for Geoffrey that's right
I thought your move Queen c4 is played
and black this is a real bummer when you
got two minutes left but importantly the
good news is you only have one move to
make and but what move is it that's
that's the bad news
you've got so many different there's
different thoughts of maybe squirming
with the king as well they're probably
all bad thoughts but they're thought for
example I don't want to do it but
there's like Ewing age to know so he
does play wreck up d3 so this is his
official try oh you just saw her fifties
yeah okay so we walk back we kind of
predicted that and I'm still upset with
that rook on f8 of course h5 is still
coming so black needs a nice move here
just able to find something but my
strange idea was rook b1
but then I think I'm worried about rook
b2 c3 yeah I don't know yeah we're also
just trading off your one active piece
well if rook takes b1 I was I thought it
was gonna be pretty happy with Queen
takes d3 see like if nothing else
couldn't I do here here and then claim
that I'm the one who's in charge maybe
you could claim that yeah yeah maybe
this is there's a difficult position
that you know
on f8 let me just say it's him let's
just go back a second and it felt like
the rooks III already there's different
things he could have done this was like
the old school it's like how Wesley so
likes the pleasure you know just nice
and easy
look see one though and that wasn't my
movie of choice especially committing to
this wreck f8 thing I guess maybe
Geoffrey calculated something kind of
concrete and he said rook f8 these two
pieces are enough but I guess we're not
really seeing it yet well you know it's
easy to miss something here especially
like you know these rooks in this
position are doing kind of this
incredible defensive dance but like I
said it's kind of to be expected when
you put your rook on a fate that blacks
gonna have something so last move for
Geoffrey it's all the time control you
pick he almost picks up the rook he's
got the hand to the forehead he's not
sure anyone a 1 is okay alright so
obviously the guy wants to deliver some
kind of mate with Queen c1 somehow
someway he's gonna set up the first
drink battery but with this time control
I believe Group C is actually totally
finished totally finished oh well they
think about that let's take a look and
maybe see how those games ended up
alright so we had LCM Elgin drew I
thought he had a nice position
I don't like did he drew this final
position honestly it feels to me like
he's the one who still has some juice
yeah I was with with the Knights against
that the bad bishop it feels like
something a little surprising that he
did that maybe I'll talk to later then
that's what he thought this game was
kind of equal ish the entire game
I'm sure mistakes were made on both
sides but I was an equalist game from
the start let's just look at this
position they started with they had that
thing from the very beginning and what
of course we had Brandon's beautiful win
he's now leading group C yeah by a clear
1/2 point you know
I just I'm intimidated by kids who are
sixteen fifty fifty about to become a GM
in college
hey this beautiful thing at Columbia
yeah my goodness come on go go you don't
need to be here go to back to Columbia
we don't need to be upstaged by these
kids go cure a disease that's right
let's check out Samuels game sure and we
got hurt in deciding it got really
excited okay and this was the Ark he
mention that holy moly let's go to where
we left it which was this incredible end
game and we left it let me find this
thing see for vision fi this is where we
left it I've checked this move out this
is a hard position I wasn't certain what
was going on here a six of course got to
get the Benko counterplay that's pretty
nice actually
I actually I don't understand it so he's
saying what if just B takes a six he's
saying that I think the word Banco is a
nice term because he's saying that my
play on the queenside is going to be
sufficient to hold you off and it might
be true ya know this is it's where it's
almost the same structure where it's
surprising those you're allowing the
bishop to hang out on c3 yeah so at
least it feels like white should be
better here very much so in fact there's
definite pressure on the a pawn though
right or I guess rook b8 was played I
was expecting rook a there at first
glance and then there's just a question
what he gonna do after a three I'll put
the right back on b8 you know he's gonna
play king c1 and walk it out okay Bishop
e3 mrs. Levi
f 4 f 4 is a really interesting movie
that I'm not sure I understand
the natural idea looks like like g5 I
guess and then so you're gonna make
cycling have to take on e6 and then play
g5 yeah maybe even f5 I think maybe
taking and then f5 is the plan because
the rook on d1 is being stymied on d5
sorry but it's obviously really
complicated check to the misérable point
a for going back check to the bishop
King a2
haha I believe in whites position mostly
because his pieces are strong not so
much because of this pawn yeah I guess
black is really kind of all-in on
finding something against both like the
king in this little Queen side boom boom
and I'm gonna sacrifice a piece whoa and
that's how we get it all right so this
son game Oh intuitively white white
should at least have I think nothing to
fear one fear you could have is that he
gets beat and a rook and Bishop versus
thing later but honestly the pawns are
very promising especially because the
white king is there to Shepherd red the
pawns so so of course it's always harder
to get past the the dark squares with
the dark square Bishop on the board but
he's already got c3b for kind of a five
whenever he wants it and it's hard for
black to get counter play on the Kings
side that would be great if you know if
that pawn on g4 we're stuck on g3 so no
but it's pretty safe and so this looks
Pleasant I assume they're gonna take a
little break right now and take a moment
collective thoughts make thoughts yeah
well the other games this one has been
opposite color madness for a while I
think that's gonna be a draw now that
the stuff is off let's just assume
that's gonna head to draw yeah it's no
way to break through and then Ganguly
actually I was really I liked this game
from a variety of perspectives
like the game with with Jeffery against
Howell the this game has been one where
black has been white has been pressing
on the Kings site for a very long time
and I don't know if you're familiar with
this position that you said you were I
do hope so this is the Fisher's
old-school idea of course where you get
the Carlsbad structure and one thing
that was a revelation to me here was
that white can give black you can say
okay you can achieve all your dreams and
you're allowed to take that bishop the
knight excuse me on 83 but that I'm not
gonna care that much yeah and I'm still
gonna say I'm playing for 95 I'm gonna
say that this Knight is terrible and so
we get this nice maneuvering game now
where I liked it from white because a
simple plan of building up on the e-file
and then we're gonna start playing h4
and h5 stuff and before you see this
with reverse colors with the Queens
gambit declined a lot yeah we're just
gonna shut try to shut down the counter
play so yeah so I have seen this line
quite a bit yeah
so level with you this this line scares
me a little bit and so I actually go for
a king sized pink I play g6 and Bishop
g7 no and then I actually like to play
Bishop f5 there and offer the trade of
the the bishops with Bishop f5 and G
takes f 5 and that's kind of the the
setup I I go for against this but
straight Carlsbad has has never really
been appealing to me right no it's a
little scary and the good news is at
least black is getting a little play on
the C pawn yeah look at that it's very
pleasant though the way White's just
building things up I'm from squares a
for obviously a critical attempt
oh man look at all that and so it looks
equally SH however I think it's fair to
say that the attack is still gonna
continue here yeah this is the kind of
thing where I can imagine the computer
in fact the entire time I know that the
computer says black is simply fine but
on a practical level it's really hard to
avoid falling apart and in addition to
the king the knight on b8 that it was
terrible on c6 and now it's terrible on
da gotten worse I think so I don't know
it's hard to believe like the white just
seems to have kind of free reign over
over anywhere it wants to go and III
don't I don't understand how black can
be okay here but and one question why
it's asking obviously that's what's
wrong with Queen b1 yeah I guess it's
got to be f5 as a response but but then
Knight a5 tough move to play again yeah
he white just instead plays ninety five
himself kind of I kind of like it
whether whether or not Queen D one was
strong just because on 95 we're saying
that the Queen has so many jobs here
it's messing with you here messing with
you here and you got to worry about the
back step as well right
oh let's try to do this thing where I
touch it I'm trying to do it doesn't
work for me now hold on I want to touch
it
oh you sometimes I can touch it and it
shows me all the different squares that
he goes to I'm doing that but that might
be disabled yeah I said there was a tech
team back there they didn't like me
doing that sometimes I really like the
way it lights up the board of the Queen
in the late middle game vision so that
looks very pleasant let's check in on
Sam's amazing defense Sam Shanklin that
is yeah he's still fighting hard I guess
and in the last move 93 White has just
announced he's ready to
see the rooks traded all right now my
initial response there was that black
was definitely going to be happy if he
got that trade as black I think I'm very
happy with the way this game's kind of
gone them not only now I'm able to trade
the rooks but also my my h-bond did make
it a little bit up the board I can kind
of get safely to h3 and then and let's
just say that this whole thing the very
fact that White's alive is surprising to
both of us after that yeah let's just
remember this was our thing and it
looked like the end of the game and now
we're here where it is a big bonus for
black that he gets to trade the rook but
he but White has not totally lost
why does not totally loss and a lot of
it has to do with the opposite color
bishop let me take a moment here and
explain something that I know I've
taught a lot where this concept I know
it is hard for people imagine well I
don't know how it maybe I'll just make
it as a joke they talk a lot about
diversity now in the value of diversity
and sometimes I don't know what they're
talking about like diversity of what
right on the chessboard there's a times
though where diversity is very important
and here Black is undiversified verse
you can think of your portfolio being
diverse you don't want to be
concentrated on the same business and
that's what the rooks are doing they
duplicate each other's function whereas
the white rook complements both the
bishop in the knight now sometimes you
can have a rook and Knight against two
rooks and here we have a rook and two
miners against the two rooks and in both
cases it's a big achievement for black
to exchange it off and what we'll see
now is that because the white rook is
gone black's rook can dream of being the
hero he did take on d2 even white took
back being the hero and invade
to create really a second weakness which
is this guy over here and there's that
that guy is gonna come under a lot of
stress we can obviously if we put a rook
here is they'll become under stress and
if we play a five a four it'll come
under stress so there it's doing the
little bubbles how come I didn't get
bubbles before I couldn't so h4 was
played it really feels like blacks
gotten gotten what he wanted I still
don't see exactly the path the path in
for the black rook maybe through f7 and
then g7 but I think here's a way to talk
about black has two weaknesses to probe
white with one is white has to worry
about this pawn and it will go to h3
that's a light square black owns the
light squares it is going to h3 now is
it maybe it possible for black to do a
white to do a blockade on h2 yes but
this is where the principle of two
weaknesses comes in and you've got to
worry then about the rook coming in to
talk to this guy so it's going to be two
things on opposite sides of the board
that white has to worry about and the
Knights as we know are not great at
moving across the board right right the
rook this is really by the way a thing
that people should know is like a lot of
times people's are I wait let me just
speak for myself when I was a kid I was
prejudiced for the two pieces against
the rook and where you see that a lot is
in the opening or early middle game the
two miners will just devastate the room
because the rook doesn't have all this
beautiful open space but now we come to
the later phase of the game the rook is
going to be an absolute beast
right it can cover so much ground so
quickly and it's yeah this is this is a
nightmare for Sam here
so even though he defended well it looks
like he's still gonna be toast but the
game was thought open it's not over I
agree he played Knight f4 claiming that
he can stop you from going h3 but
honestly I don't think it's I don't
think it's ultimately gonna happen okay
this is a tactical attempt though that
white at least needs to pay attention to
there's two problems now for whites to
think about 96 and Knight g6 ok good
move so at least there are some
practical questions now for so the move
I want to play I believe is well first
of all I might want to give a check on
d8 and then after that I think I want to
play rook h8 if I can and just say h3
I'm gonna do it and then I'm gonna do h2
and then I'm gonna do h1 ok why are you
giving me a check because I I if your
King runs to e2 then I think it might be
a bit uncomfortably far away from the a
pawn and same thing with what c2 is it's
just kind of centralized right now I
think he followed your idea but I like
what he did that he just played Brooke
case just ricocheted no Jack because the
the king of I gave the King a chance to
improve itself because maybe you do want
to be it with a little closer yeah ok so
let's think if Sam obviously needs some
good tricks here now one
oh I'll just play a move and see if I
can make something happen let's try this
one
I yeah I want to play and we play a ch3
I want to say I don't care okay is
there's 98 I see so if were cage 690 I
think I can still do this though it
might be able still do this
absolutely maybe even just wreck up two
and then in the final position
so King see ya King see 896 you know
okay good let's try again
so night if for Brooke 88 Sam is
contemplating this let's just say Knight
h3 is a moral failing you can push you
away with Bishop g2 at some point even
immediately yeah
so what to do could I do it doesn't look
Pleasant I wanted to say I don't like
the look of it so I don't have time to
play h3 cuz you have an 83 so I like
your can't your rooks attack well yeah
but I wanted to play h3 you take Marik I
play h2 but then you have night g3
what's what I was trying to say to stop
the pot your rook da now might be
pleasant yeah cuz now if King III I got
to worry about that business let's just
say Knight 6 H 5 is not a happy camper
move there's also just Rick h6 they're
kind of renewing renewing the threat of
h3
I'm not seeing it I'm really not seeing
it there's maybe Nate G for instead of
night age five and then I'll just say
there's really no score on the H file
for you to call your own I mean but yeah
I can do well a lot of sports
I got rook h7 for example rugby eights
of thought - yeah and then this is yeah
it's a time to play to play night h3 and
just kind of it's always gonna be nice
if you're gonna do a blockade it's gonna
be on h2 right yeah so 92 as well was
another idea and this would be
submitting to abject terror yeah right
this is nightmarish okay so that's fun
now let's just say if Sam somehow holds
this this will be obviously key in
saving his tournament one thing I also
want to say I with purchased personal
experience in playing these long
tournaments if you get a couple games
that go the distance you will your
system will be wrecked and thankfully
it's only one game a day but imagine you
get several days of 80 move games man
you're just gonna be wrecked so you know
having daro spirits getting a draw in
the first round even though I'm sure he
wanted more he gets to go relax you know
and think about his next opponent and
Sam's just in suffering and yes it's
definitely gonna be a long day for Sam
let's take a look at a Jefferies game
right see what he's he's been up to so
we had the famous rook ft3 they got a
little time to think about it
rook a one Queen f4 Queen c2 Queen e3
and he's saying there's no way for you
to talk to my back rank he's somehow got
it all covered
and Jeffrey is of course dreaming about
bringing the other rook in what h5 is
coming so here's maybe an idea what if I
play King g7 can I use this H pawn idea
against you almost with the idea for a
KJ mm-hmm I'm sure he's thinking about
it and here there's a couple thoughts
Queen g5 being one of them
but it I I don't know what else besides
the Kennedy said that rook on f8 has to
get in
but so let's just back step so queen F
for Queen c2 Queen III and if King g7
let's say Queen g5 we could also play
Queen afford the the drama was that
you're letting me into that square yes
oh yeah and it's just tough to cover all
these scores for white but I think what
why you can hope for though is that even
if you check me I might at some point be
able to run and as and I you know I'm
hoping that I'm old black will also have
grief yeah you know black will also have
free but yeah I think your move King g7
is the big candidate move I don't see
anything else at least obvious so we're
expecting probably a probably expecting
Sam to fall then and what do you think
do you think Jeffrey's gonna be able to
pull this out and the long runner is
it's just what haven't maybe enough
defensive resource heads a lot on this
move with King g7 Daniel he could
honestly I could see Geoffrey losing
this to I've seen these kinds of things
it's like the the white initiative will
become very fast if a little up in the
air you want to take another quick look
at what's going on in the beaker sure oh
yeah let's look at this game alright so
blonds of role when we left it it was
about here before check to the miserable
King and then a five so very simple
trick is that if you snip I have this
and it in general I think also white
wants to say that he'd like to keep his
pawns on dark squares right so that they
don't become blockaded if you'd played
b5 will be harder cos so you know stick
a bishop on a5 or something like
so king d5 rook a6 I'm sure there was a
oh right there's not other moves you got
to go to a6 and now white is thinking
about something like c4 so Bishop every
warranted c4 is trying to come from
behind right with Bishop d2 so we have
ourselves a technical position where it
looks though that white should be let's
call it either better or winning I you
definitely pick the white pieces I think
I think a wins almost more likely than a
draw here it's at least from my personal
experience the pawns always get through
well imagine if this Bishop gets here
they just they'll always get through
just I I can never I can never hold them
off so maybe this rule ended on a six in
anticipation of something like that so
it can play b5 and have that that a pawn
still defended okay why don't you play a
couple so I wanted to play start with c4
it's the most natural and then maybe
I'll play a b5 here
and I just wanted to push straight on
ahead with with b6 now I do have drawing
thoughts now Bishop a5 okay the rook and
I don't know if it's really a draw but I
have chances because my King is active
and I can come over here so for example
snip snip
and then I don't know let's just either
a six or one of these squares right
right I'm can I just I can just play
Rick p7 may be either g6 or g5
what if I play rook f7 and try to be
good you should be you should be
thinking about stuff like this but
that's it so this is another this would
be another story but well I think this
is the kind of thing we're gonna be
looking at and that white is considering
with c4 he's trying to come up with a
way to deny black all counterplay the
good news for black is the rook on a6 is
at least a little bit funky and the
black king has dreams of maybe counter
play with King efore f3 for example in
this position where I took on a5 the
King could also dream about doing
something like this later and maybe even
that's too much because of c5 but these
are the things that they're these are
the things that are here they're
thinking about yeah all right and then
there's the two other games and in the B
group sure let's take a look at maybe
maybe one eventually was played
we had 93 invade okay seven
black is holding on for dear life my
sensitivity this would be lost is
because the night is so terrible but
white definitely still has to find the
way through it's almost like blacks
whites Queen wants to be on both b8 and
hey seven at the same time but
unfortunately those are against the
rules
yeah there's like the g5 ponies is
probably going to fall I think that that
might be what if I just play rook aged
five and then Knight that's that's a
totally brutal way to play him
that's very young unpleasant of you
he gave a check on h7 maybe preventing
something like even Queen g7 ideas we're
gonna pretend that King f8 is forced say
just draw a cage v I don't see it
very very difficult for black regardless
well wait a second isn't there a dirty
trick here can I do this check goodness
oh goodness that yeah no I think he's
thinking about it cuz maybe there's some
no on f6 I got that one family there's
still 96 there it's still nice when they
were saying yeah disaster so that looks
like the end of the world that white is
dreaming about what's game-ending
he's just thinking about so Queen each
it I guess King e7 and then no good move
key Nisa but now we have a variety of
nice things like even Queenie yeah yeah
yeah they think it's it's too much it's
too much to give up I guess Queen g8
black might be hoping for rook a to
here's another brutal thing look at this
snip snip
rook h8 and then what do you do oh I
guess you can play Knight d7 yeah not a
very pleasant thing to do but you know
you can play Knight d7 maybe you're
gonna live so let's not do it okay but
it's too much it's definitely just too
much let's look at what happened here so
it went and then h6 he has some notion
here Oh which is that if Queens you said
no Queen is on the board yep so we we
found the tactic and he just found a
cooler way of doing it with this still
Queen g8 maybe two no Queen g8 there's
Queen f6 oh it's over for black here so
I think we're calling this one for
Ganguly and I just want to go back a
second and show people this Carlsbad
structure if you don't want to learn any
kind of theory against the car oh this
is a beautiful thing to do even Caleb
system with playing g6 you still do the
same thing you just put all your pieces
aiming it for me five claim that the
knight on c6 is terrible and say later
in the game no matter what you do even
though it looks like it's not that big
of a deal I will waste you oh yeah that
is my plan
time will come your time will come yeah
and then I think there's just one last
game still still in play with Grigory
and I against caboose game we're gonna
call that a girl call it a draw
oh yeah we've we've seen this well we
still got Sam on the board though that's
the big game right oh yeah oh yeah
oh we're nearing nearing the end of our
broadcast in the last game going on to
the P group so I guess we'll take one
last look at Sam Shanklin and then maybe
you and I on our standings and see what
it looks like so we were looking at this
position it was hard to say what white
should do 94 94 yeah it's very simple
because now the night on g4 can't move
the pawn on h3 is coming it's very very
you know even fish about three threats
writer Bishop d7 bridge just one nice
thing too about this beautiful rook that
we're talking about before is the White
King doesn't know he's all of them all
of the white pieces are stretched
between the king the king of the H pawn
and the a two point yeah and the King
especially is this like Oh bro I don't
know where I'm supposed to go we'll just
hang out in the middle yeah one defense
for me and he can't cross the line King
III Bishop d7 it's all over so I guess
that's nearing the end almost anything
Bishop d7 so they you let the pond
through such a bummer for Sam because
let me just say about this Berlin thing
you know first of all other commentators
not me
other commentators as I see the Berlin
they groan and be like oh it's just
gonna be another draw I disagree this
thing is a beautiful it's almost like
it's its own game like some openings
that you should call it the Berlin game
or something like that because it has
its own rules and this one was
definitely example where blacks pieces
exploded and we get really great tactics
like this one and then a great defensive
tribe by Sam for King h3 it's not enough
but for a moment it was like oh man
maybe he's gonna survive finding a way
yeah yeah
but yes so in this final position we
really do expect
well not final position but we expect
you know black to kind of be able to
pull this through it's just too much for
white and right maybe the the top seed
quite possibly going going down in the
first round here so it's gonna be tough
for him right now come back and as we
close here I just want to remind people
that keep keep watching this Geoffrey he
only LuAnn Jones and us chess champs
calm that's the the place to check it
all out all the games are still gonna be
broadcast up there and I believe we're
gonna take a quick look at maybe the
standings in the C group a the a group
and the B groups still a lot of games in
progress
but this is finalized now so Brandon
Jacobsen taking a half point lead out of
the first round with that wonderful win
over Christian is peaceful results and
the other two games maybe some some
chances there that yeah I thought the L
Shan really had a chance enough yeah and
with that in mind I think that's gonna
be that's gonna be it for us you guys
can join us here tomorrow as well as
pretty much every round here at 3:30
p.m. that's when we'll go on the games
all start at 1:00 p.m. as always you're
welcome to watch that on us chess chance
comm you're welcome to follow along in
the the YouTube channel and anything you
want to add Jesse before we we call it a
day beautiful games they're very
fighting I'm looking forward to it
tomorrow alright thank you for joining
us
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you